Doug McMillan might be the most
important CEO in the world that's
because he is the CEO of Walmart which
is the largest company in the world both
by revenue and the sheer number of
people they employ what is Walmart's
role in our nation and around the world
we're dedicated to a purpose it's a team
dedicated to serving others that's
basically the essence of the place and
if I could boil Walmart down to one word
it'd be serve and if you gave me two
words it'd be servant leadership because
that's what I see and that's who I think
we are the thing that I love about that
answer is that you keep people safe you
keep people safe first and then
everything else sort of falls into place
you do have high expectations for your
people yourself your organization but
not at any cost that taking care of
people and pushing harder it's in that
order which I think is a beautiful thing